[Music]
[Applause]
we were talking about Bill Belichick
having a press conference today and if
you could ask the following question
Todd give Mike Reese the question if you
were there today that you would have
asked Bill Belichick hey coach in spite
of all your success and all the Super
Bowl wins what would you say to those
who feel like you're in the hot seat
right now okay let's bring in Mike Reese
the great reporter covers the Patriots
for the mothership he was at the press
conference how do you think first of all
good morning Mike how do you think coach
would answer that question from Todd
Fritz good morning Dan honored to be
with you
um hey I'm just focused on the Saints
been a big game against the Saints
is focusing on what I can control
really that that's he wouldn't he
wouldn't uh even tiptoe towards that at
all
not at all okay
this is uh his 24th year and I think
every Wednesday press conference starts
the same way he comes in and he talks
about the team they're facing gives like
a detailed scouting breakdown and then
any question that you ask that doesn't
connect to that game or that team he's a
master deflector he just won't he won't
entertain it what's the difference
between the local coverage of the
Patriots and the national coverage
that's a good question
um I would say the national will focus
on the bigger picture
hey is he on the hot seat right
um
where's this thing headed
the local coverage we've got like
literally as we talked in within the
last 10 minutes we've had a trade
agreement for a cornerback JC Jackson uh
so we're drilling down on those details
uh who's coming back to practice what
you know what what's the team look like
this week to try to get him back in the
win column so probably a little more
micro in Focus than the big picture of
could this be the are we looking at the
end here of of this run I mentioned this
yesterday a couple of times so I'm
asking my audience to bear with me would
Bill Belichick the GM fire Bill
Belichick the coach
I don't think he would then he
he he doesn't really believe I don't
want to say he doesn't believe in it but
I think he's a traditionalist he's old
school in the sense of he he likes the
the patience model
you know so like what Pittsburgh does
right they have a bad year they have a
couple bad years like generally
they're going to stick with their coach
they're going to stick with their
structure they're going to give their
people in place a chance to work it out
um so I think
to me when I think about Bill Belichick
the way he views things I think he comes
from that school and I think he would
demand better results but he wouldn't go
for the hook
how important do you think it is for
Robert Kraft to have Bill Belichick
break Don Shula's record as his head
coach
I think in his heart a heart Stan that's
what he wants but I don't think that
it's a a hundred percent given that he's
willing to say it's happening no matter
what and they had a event an event about
a month ago here at the stadium
they have new construction and they had
a ribbon cutting and I asked Robert
Kraft about being out on the practice
field with Bill Belichick before the
first game
and he looked me in the eye Dan and he
goes you know he wanted me out there he
wanted to show me something and then he
said to me
make no mistake it's about winning
and to me it was a point he seemed to
want to get across like yeah we gotta
win this is about winning you know so
and that Echoes something he had said
before too and I don't know if Patriot
fans are used to that slow September
because Bill always it felt like he used
September like his preseason and then
the season started like now but you had
Brady and Brady was always the light at
the end of the tunnel this is a team
that's not relevant not interesting and
not threatening uh are are we supposed
to expect something different from the
Patriots from now on
no no the standard is to be Robert Kraft
has said the standard is playoffs like
got to get to the playoffs and anything
can happen and I think your point Dan is
is well taken as we've gotten further
away from Tom Brady
the numbers are not good numbers sub 500
record since 2000 the last playoff win
Super Bowl over the Rams yeah so this is
what they are
and so yeah like that that's what it is
the bottom line
because you look around the Jets are are
going to get better
um they have more Talent they're more
interesting the bills are formidable
Miami is you know potentially great so
it's a tough division there what if they
go five and twelve
I think that puts Robert Kraft in a very
tough position and what what does that 5
and 12 look like then so to me the first
three games this year I thought they
were competitive against Philly one of
the best teams in the league I thought
they were competitive against Miami one
of the better teams in the league
they each went out against the Jets
probably fortunate right that Aaron
Rodgers wasn't there and then it got
away from them fast against the Cowboys
in the second quarter and they were
outclassed so if it looks like 5 and 12
and most of the games were what we saw
this past Sunday against the Cowboys
think you start asking the hard question
is it is it is it time to to move on
but if it looks closer to the first
three games
to me that's a tough spot for Robert
Kraft
what was that like when Brady came back
this year
was there any awkwardness to it
I wouldn't say awkwardness
um to me as and I've covered them now
you know I did all the time I did even
before Tom when Pete Carroll was the
coach
what I felt was
a cross-section between everything
you're talking about Dan like they gotta
move on from the past yeah it's a new
era
but here they are celebrating the past
so to me it was like a conflict right
but but they they had to do it because I
think it was important to the crafts
that the first opportunity they had to
celebrate Tom Brady
as a retired player was as a patriot
they want to make sure people remember
him as a patron more than anything else
does Belichick know you by name
he does and the only reason I can
confirm that then is that after this
most recent game against the Cowboys
when I asked him about Mac Jones being
pulled from the game with three minutes
41 seconds left in the third quarter uh
he told me that he didn't think there
was any point of leaving him in the game
so I followed up
and I said will Mac Jones be starting
this week against the Saints
and he looked at me and he said
I just said I didn't see any point of
leaving him in the game Mike
he might have thought you were the Mike
linebacker then you know oh my God
my only brush with well I've been on the
podium when they won the Super Bowl so
that's the only time I've really spoken
to him but I was there for the butt
fumble game
and he came out of the locker room I'm
with Tony Dungy and Rodney Harrison and
it's a receiving line of sorts so he's
like hey coach good to see you hey
Rodney and then I put my hand down and
he just blew right by me and I was like
all right I'll get you next I'll get you
after the game yeah yeah don't get tied
up here pregame stuff so
probably didn't know who I was maybe he
did that's why he blew right by me well
you know keep fighting a good fight let
us know if you need fritzy to come up
and kind of stir up that press
conference next week
good stuff Dan I appreciate being on
with you thank you bud that's Mike Reese
he covers the Patriots for the
Mothership
didn't realize he had been there uh that
long time wait can I get Mike uh real
quick one more time did we Mike I'm with
you okay I'm with you um take me back to
Pete Carroll and why it didn't work then
but it works now
so it was such a contrast to what they
had with Bill Parcells so remember
Parcells was here in New England
93 to 96. and this was like the
antithesis of the parcels program here
you have Pete Carroll coming in
you know pumping his fists and hey let's
get this going competition and it was
almost too much of a pendulum swing okay
for what they had prior
and I would say the expectation Parcells
had him in the Super Bowl his last year
Pete was 500 competitive but just not at
that that same level it was just too too
big of a swing Dan from one culture to
really the other culture all right thank
you Mike we appreciate it